це знаменита американська авіабаза
Rammstein на півдні Німеччини яка у часи
холодної війни була основною
логістичною базою американських збройних
сил у Європі А нині є місцем зустрічі
контактної групи допомоги Україні
сьогодні відбувався так званий Rammstein
5 тобто 5-та за ліком конференція але це
друга насправді конференція яка
відбувалася саме в цьому місті на цій
авіабазі вже на початку зустрічі у
вступному слові глава пентагону
войтостін подав символічний сигнал
заявивши про новий пакет допомоги
Україні який напередодні затвердив
президент США джубайден Україна отримає
додаткові
675 млн доларів до цього пакету увійдуть
постачання нових ракет harm гаубиць 105
мм артилерійських боєприпасів та
автомобілів Hands а також броньованих
машин швидкої допомоги
підкреслив що військову допомогу Україні
довела свою ефективність Він сказав що
докази успіхів наших зусиль ми бачимо на
полях боїв А те що учасників зустрічі у
рамштані явно надихають успіхи Україні у
України у війні було відчутно також
в інших учасників
конференції але ось там також підкреслив
що зараз у війні України проти Росії
відбувається ключовий черговий ключовий
момент за його словами змінюється
обличчя війни і це вимагає від
також від рамштайну а зміни певної зміни
обличчя самого цього формату допомоги а
важливо в цьому зв'язку що через 4
місяці після
першої конференції у Rammstein за
словами остіна дуже важливо
зробити допомогу військово-технічну
допомогу Україні
довгостроковою Раніше вона була
розрахована
ситуативно на те щоб дати відповідь
російській агресії тепер судячи з усього
західні союзники України розуміють що ця
війна може тривати не один місяць і тому
відповідно і допомога має бути
розрахована і промислові потужності
запущені для виробництва озброєнь які
потрібні Україні тобто Ось він
підкреслив що задовольнити потреби
України на оборону на тривалий період а
цікаво що цей месендз меседж повторювали
і учасники з інших країн зокрема
Німеччини ось щодо Німеччини хотілося
окремо наголосити і Остін
дуже ну відзначав
внесок Німеччини особливо у захисті
українського повітря Але
від агресії але
важливо відзначити що Німеччина яке
господарем зустрічі
на території Німеччини саме відбувається
конференція її
загалом внесок експерти
оцінюють довольно скромно що стосується
постачань конкретна Україні тих чи інших
озброєнь і конкретно запиту України до
цієї країни
Міністерка оборони
Німеччини Крістіна ламберг
виходячись до журналістів мусила
відповідати на запитання в тому числі
які стосувалися і
питань
допомоги Україні і того ж чому Німеччина
досі не постачає
українцям
важку техніку про яку вони просять
міністр оборони вийшла до журналістів
разом з міністром оборони Нідерландів
кайсою олландгрен заявила що формат
рамштайна добре себе проявив у підтримці
України що українці ведуть хоробру
боротьбу проти Росії і підкреслила що
вона в цілому задоволена тим як
допомагають Україні Німеччина разом з
нідерландами згадавши про спільні
проставки протитанкових гаубиць та
іншого обладнання з нового Що вона
анонсувала це те що будуть проводитися
навчання українських військових а щодо
поводження з вибуховими речовинами
ближче до змінами поводження змінами і
це навчання буде відбуватися разом з
нідерландами коли її запитали про
конкретну скільки саме українців будуть
навчатися вона відповіла що йдеться про
приблизно 20 осіб
зараз починається невеликий дощик тут у
рамштайні і якраз У цьому зв'язку
говорячи про погоду і про те що ми маємо
Зараз осінь варто
згадати про так званий зимовий пакет
який партнери України
готують для них про це також сказала
німецька Міністерка оборони Крістін
ламбрихт Вона сказала що зимовий пакет
включатиме з німецького боку намети
електрогенератори тобто те що
українським бійцям знадобиться взимку На
жаль з мого погляду у сказаному ламбрехт
грандіозних анонсів не було і конкретики
було досить мало на відміну від першого
Rammstein де були анонсовані наприклад
німецькі гепарди
зараз про іншу важку техніку у Німеччині
поки не йдеться про техніку радянського
зразка
тому що
аргументація Берліна така що
сучасні
леопарди для них потрібно українських
військових дуже довго
перенавчати в той час як він війна
вимагає швидких відповідей і Тому поки
відбуватиметься навчання
можуть бути втрачені людські життя це
така
аргументація Крістін ламбрех тому
підсумовуючи сказане вона заявила що ми
будемо надалі орієнтуватися на потреби
України але робитимемо ставку все ж таки
на узгодження цих потреб і того що буде
постачати Німеччина із партнерами
Німеччини
ось власне і все
більшою конкретики Ми сподіваємося
почути пізніше сьогодні а також а також
у найближчі дні коли будуть сказано про
те що саме в
партнери а їх тут близько 40
країн які беруть участь у конференції
Rammstein то саме що саме партнери
конкретного пообіцяли Києва